there's a party going down Pino I'm  sorry to hear about your father who is  capable you've worked on your father's  cars and made us coffee at all Makino  or full of little surprises check this  out too true all these want to see  something cool think about this Kaito I  haven't done anything good my whole life  we've been wasting our potential you a  little bit more than me the city needs  our help  we could be heroes looking these on  weapons yes we will  but no tights good are you ready to die  I control the fly  The Green Hornet has been attracting a  lot of attention because you don't have  fighting the experience that's oh man  he's not my man not where it's put  science were just platonic friends yes I  want the head of the Green Hornet in the  secret mission take my hand come with me  on this adventure I'd go with you but I  don't want to touch you  just give it to me for